well thank you for spending spending a
little bit of lunch time with me and
know everybody's here for the talk and
not the food but before I begin if
anybody wants slides or follow-up
questions you want to pass this around
just throw your email address on there
and I'll send everything out after the
fact so weird Laurie go Laurie how I do
everything is let's do this guy thank
you for having me I'd like to start with
quote about MIT and as Laurie said I'm a
classical political philosophy buted I
suck at math in the circuit science or
did until I started doing this and it
fascinates me how both are converging
and that's really the story we're going
to talk about today is where technology
where data where people were process our
meeting to solve the problems of
legislative data and law itself so in
2011 The Guardian wrote the
Massachusetts Institute of Technology
has led the world into the future for
more than a hundred and fifty years with
scientific innovations its brainwaves
keep the u.s. a superpower but what
makes the university such a fertile
ground for brilliant ideas well in my
experience my brief experience with with
civic media here it's people like you
thin
it's people like Lori people like Nicole
Andrew I don't know if Andrews around
here oh hey Andrew it's right here and
you guys thank you for having me and
being fabulous and being part of this
MIT community where I come in is from
the government side everything if you
remember nothing else today it's that
the problems we face as citizens as
researchers as journalists on the
outside of government with technology
and access are equal to and opposite the
problems faced by people in government
who have to do this stuff who have to
produce the information have to post
things on the web and as we'll see
fixing the problems we have as citizens
getting from denied to open
is a process of helping both inside and
outside of government and this beautiful
artwork here I have to credit to Alexis
Ohanian this is a skewed version of his
book cover without their permission
that's part of the story we're going to
talk about today is we're getting from
the denied to the open with law and
legislation and sometimes without
people's permission and we will discuss
what that actually means for democracy
today so before I get too far I want to
tell you a little bit about us we're the
open gov foundation a scrappy
nonpartisan nonprofit working to bring
the best tools and ideas from the tech
world into government where it's sorely
needed this is our github page if you
want to fork us my developers would love
that that's where you can find all of
our code for what we're talking about
today we were born actually from inside
Congress as Laura mentioned I worked for
congressman darrell Issa and the
Oversight Committee in the US House and
we were born actually from a hack so
when the Stop Online Piracy started that
whole SOPA PIPA fight about a year and a
half ago Darrell was the first guy in
the house to raise his hand and say you
know this shall not pass but it was
really late in the game we were just as
surprised as people on the outside we
didn't have the lobbyist money we didn't
have the support and we didn't have the
time so what do we do we walked into a
room to try to hack the legislative
process open with open source software
that was our first tool called Madison
which is what instigated the open gov
foundation so Madison I'll talk about
that a little bit at the end it was
essentially a crowdsource legislative
tool we used to diagnose problems with
SOPA so to get all the expertise much of
which is in this room into the process
and also deliver an alternative the
right-left collaboratively on the
internet accountably where everyone can
weigh in and participate this is what
Madison looked like at the time you can
see it's pretty stripped down simple but
it opened up the legislative data giving
people a way to annotate comment ask
questions discuss do something with that
information
this is legislative process on the
internet it's ugly but it worked so the
problems we're all facing in government
are pretty maddening just yesterday a
certain other cambridge-based university
that also likes crimson released a study
a pretty sobering one that says more
than that more than 75% oh yeah more
than 75% of young Americans are
disengaged they don't care to become
engaged but you guys are engaged and
you're engaged in a really high-tech way
with the hacker ethos alive and well and
you guys here can convene these two
people this is my co-founder tardis
Manisa and ethan talking at the Civic
media night conference last year you
guys are bringing together left and
right science and civics that's what
this discussion and that's what these
problems all revolve around and you more
than most people know it's at stake for
those of you who don't know this is
Aaron Swartz the legal issues that he
was facing they're real this is an
academic the the things we're going to
talk about today the problems of access
of equal protection of law of the
ability to participate are far more than
academic it's real-life people go to
jail or worse for putting this
information in the Internet
so what you guys know technology well
it's all about people so the technology
only serves what we're trying to do here
is as a society it means nothing if it
isn't helping everyday people secure
their rights in this country and protect
themselves from the powerful hold
government accountable whether the
powerful is a corporation or government
all we're doing is strengthening
citizen's right to participate access
information and secure equal protection
now everybody knows America is supposed
to deliver the freedom to participate
the freedom to share ideas the freedom
to speak freely assemble petition your
government all of that depends on
information and communicating it you
cannot act unless you know and our
founding fathers knew that they knew
that everybody had to have the ability
to access what government was doing if
they were going to be able to
participate in it and hold it
accountable now back in the day the best
that they had were horses and parchment
paper that was access to the law or if
you could find your Congressman and
pigeon hole in that at some public house
that was about the best you could do
James Madison was right
the only guardian of true Liberty in the
United States is the advancement and
diffusion of knowledge now what does
that mean today it means taking the
constitution or law and legislation that
essentially still exists in a format not
a whole lot better than this if it
exists on the Internet at all and get it
to move this and that's the story that
we're we're going to talk about today
because if you don't have access to it
you can't be a citizen now think about
that for a second you cannot be a
full-fledged citizen unless you are
enjoying unfettered restriction at
restricted restriction free access to
the stuff of government which is the
words and the people who enforce those
words
our founders frankly would be horrified
if they looked at this room this
building all the whiz-bang awesome stuff
going on in here and then looked at what
government is doing that's just not good
enough paper PDFs and copyright
restrictions that's what we're dealing
with those are the problems that we're
facing today in the context of the law
so I would propose to you that the law
is the most important data set in any
community if you think about it
everything else flows from our now who
works with civic data on a daily basis
anybody reporter you're you're a
reporter what do you what do you access
for government information not a lot
okay does anybody work with spending
information transit information how
would you how would you find some
spending information to them cambridge
budget is big PDF file which is only
right it's printed paper scanned in so
you're still back in the park okay so
it's a little bit better but it's still
not there
right so there's a technology aspect to
that and then there's a process aspect
to that there's also a people aspect to
that now unfortunately we cannot fork
the human soul and and change the human
condition so we'll be talking about or
I'll be talking about the tech and the
process side of it let's begin with how
people are doing it today you're a
citizen you want to know the leash laws
what do you do you what would you do
yeah if you wanted to find out what what
the dog leash laws were what would you
do
probably Googler right that's almost
everybody's first step in first research
assistant 100 lawyers that's very
different 100 line lawyers you probably
google it if you're a citizen and if as
we all know if it doesn't show up on the
first page it ain't there sometimes any
developers in the house
developers coders you're a developer how
do you access the legal but how would
you access the information
so if you're a developer or a citizen
while you're citizen developer and
elected official by the way who just
said he gets paid too much I think this
might be the first time in history if
you got a lot of this to the
Massachusetts the laws of our of our
state no API is no bulk download can
access it what if you're a lawyer or a
legal support person you're trying to do
your job and serve clients you've got to
go through all this paper and you're not
actually able to serve as many people as
you want those are our first users by
the way our people who just want to
serve more clients who can't afford
legal assistance they want to be able to
send a link that's crazy a link to the
law that's applicable they can't do that
today
if you're a state lawmaker the first
thing that you do when a new issue comes
up as you see what everybody else has
been doing you want to see hey I'm in
Massachusetts what did they do in
Maryland what did they do it in
California you can't do that because all
the laws aren't in the same format and
often aren't in the same place if you're
a city official looking to figure out if
you're enforcement is working you want
to be able to see hey where's the hot
spots who is breaking the law where and
where do we need work you can't do that
today if you're an academic researcher
by the way this is MIT students back in
1957 doing research very different thing
today you can't find it online
same thing with journalists same thing
with business owners business owners
entrepreneurs they're hit with far more
law than most of us are everything you
see in this picture has a technical code
grab your chair that thing you are
sitting on is covered by dozens and
dozens and dozens of technical codes
where do you find those most of them are
not on the internet or if they are
they're copyrighted and you could be put
in jail or worse for trying to access
them just to do your job so all the
problems we've been discussing here as
far as accessing the law and legislation
involve discoverability problems jargon
expertise you don't know what the word
say cost and time and money design
problems data formatting it seems
daunting right there's a lot of stuff
that's wrong here with the way that
government information particularly long
legislation is accessible tonight but we
got it we can do this everybody in this
room has a skill that's applicable to
solving this problem so what I'm going
to turn to next is how this stuff is
actually made so this is where the
government side of my background comes
into play a little bit understanding how
this stuff is actually produced by the
folks inside of municipal state and
federal governments is absolutely vital
to figuring out how to solve it all
right schoolhouse rocks who remembers
this stuff how is a bill made well what
is the bill what is the law it's
actually not what you would think most
of us think the law or legislation is
this right you've got a section you've
got words on a page this is a I think
these are one of the gambling ordinances
I know it's been a hot topic up here
recently but this is it it's actually
not this this is just a snapshot of
whatever the law happens to be right now
every word on this page every sentence
is actually a mosaic it's the sum total
of all of the changes made to that law
since the state started or since the
country started or since the Magna Carta
was signed whatever the first document
is that original program each word is
the sum total of all of these little
pictures
all right so now that we know what the
law actually is it is the sum total of
all the little changes all the little
Forks made over history to what it's the
source code of the community so that's
that that's the sort of template that I
like to use to explain it to myself this
is the source code just like any program
needs that to run any community needs
the law or it can't function so how is
it made where does it start it starts
with a problem now the problem I'd like
to use today is gambling right the
problem let's say you add you don't have
convenient enough casino options you
can't go to Foxwoods can't go to
wherever my grandmother used to go to
Foxwoods all the time so Massachusetts
had a real world problem there not
enough casinos in Massachusetts the
first thing that you do when there is
that real-world problem is you've got to
figure out where the law is applicable
where in that massive hundreds of pages
of PDFs is gambling referred to I just
did a quick search on the page this is
only one of four but these are many many
many many places so you have to identify
where those are this is what it looks
like in the mosaic status now if you
remember the people who are doing this
have the same crappy technology and
tools that we do so they have to do that
massive process often by hand and they
need a hell of a lot of help
Boston can't do it by itself America
can't do it by itself so they hire who
they hire outside vendors who do this
for a little vendors like American legal
LexisNexis less law are hired by almost
every or at least in my experience every
state city county federal government to
simply help them produce the law to know
where that one word has been referenced
over time how that one word has evolved
over time
to marshal all of that information that
a legislator would need to write a bill
to fix that problem then the legislators
do their thing we're all familiar with
with how that's happens and then it goes
back to the people who produce the law
so it goes back to the clerk's and it
goes back to the vendors this is a
simple compiler but that's exactly what
they're doing they are compiling all of
those little changes to the law that
happens in a bill and getting it into
the right format so that it fits in this
it's translating a bill to the code
that's called codification
all right you know so they compile it
into the law itself and how are they
doing that well they're doing it with
the same tools as I've said over and
over that we're faced with on the
outside they're doing it in PDFs they're
doing it in work they're doing it on
crappy outdated technology with
procurement rules all on top of it
fixing this requires this and this is
the hardest thing I've found and we've
found in our experience to actually own
and mean is you gotta have a little
sympathy for the devil government sucks
the law stocks online today the ability
to access it sucks
you gotta have sympathy for the people
who are doing it there are citizens too
and they want to do their jobs better in
most cases we're assuming the best so
fixing it requires a little bit of
sympathy for the devil they're doing it
in paper they're doing it with an army
of lawyers this is Atticus Finch they're
actually doing it with a lot of them in
Chicago alone there are 17 lawyers from
vendors who keep the code updated and
publish it four times a year you need
those people to do all that work and
it's expensive states and cities are
paying hundreds of thousands if not
millions of dollars a year
a year to keep this document updated
it's essentially my track changes
operation I mean it's you need all that
people to do it well you need most of
them you need that old domain expertise
you need to know how to translate a bill
into code into the law that takes money
that takes time and that's where we come
in so now I get to talk about the
technology
the stake state decoded has anybody
heard of the state decoded checked it
out what do you know about it oh crap
there we go there we go
state 2 coded tada so all of the
problems that we were talking about
before the tech and the process not the
people we're trying to address here now
this started this whole open source
project started in Virginia with a
genius civic hacker named Waldo Jaquith
he was frustrated just like we were at
his inability to get the laws for his
own state so he said you know screw it
I'm doing it embrace that hacker ethos
and started building this for Virginia
the knight foundation who generously
funds us generously funds the Civic
Media Center and also funded Waldo took
it up to a level where we could come in
and start scaling it so Waldo did
Virginia now we're taking it to cities
and states around the country so this is
the the beautiful front end and the end
result for accessing the law where does
it start
so how does this actually happen well we
start with the code could be in a PDF
could be in a text file could be in an
RTF you have to start with the data that
they're giving us middle steps PDFs RTF
txt files then we parse that into XML
boom decoded law crazy things like the
ability to send a link the ability to
search the ability to plug into an API
and bulk downloads the ability to update
almost instantaneously all of the things
that we know we need to be full citizens
today given all the technology and the
tools we
that's what we're working on here and
it's starting to spread a little bit
started in Virginia
sunshine statutes at Florida Maryland
Baltimore San Francisco Philly Chicago
these are the ones in process we've got
about 15,000 left to go because our goal
is to get the entire corpus of law in
the United States into the same open
data format on the internet without any
restrictions that you can do anything
you want with so that's producing open
law and legislation in the 21st century
I wanted to give you a quick overview of
the the production problems which you
may or may not have been familiar with
because that explains why it sucks so
much on the outside and give you a
little bit of look at the technology
that we're using to change that now
we're changing it from the outside
sometimes governments like San Francisco
hire us to do that sometimes they say
give it will give you the data we don't
know what the hell you're going to do
with it but it's public information go
for it
sometimes you it's scraped with all the
legal implications that that has that's
what we're doing today so I'd like to I
guess open it up for questions see where
we go next
[Music]
once there's transparency so then that
equals access everyone then has a
similar ability to take advantage of the
law and I think copyright is a perfect
example of how suing you know rich
Hollywood studio of suing college
students it's completely unfair dynamic
and even though the college students
right we've in the case would cost a
quarter billion dollars right or
whatever and I think your slide there
was is the woman in the legal aid office
you know trying to explain the law
the link to that guide and be like well
no it doesn't make any sense and so I
guess I'm curious and maybe it's beyond
your purview and you can't do everything
I realized but I'm curious to what
extent there's thinking about that
connection between law and community
action are the things that the community
needs man also I disagree with the idea
that you know the casino law starts with
a problem of not accessing because you
know I don't know I mean it's a little
too short a history that yeah of what
and even really lacks sounds a little
naive in terms of what a casino does to
a community too right I mean that's the
other thing is that so so I guess that's
my question is what extent is this
project thinking about how to actually
enable people who aren't expensive law
firms and aren't well-connected
lobbyists and legislators to be able to
make use of this stuff you know and and
it seems to me that there's some of
these laws are going to be real helpful
to some people and a lot of them they're
just they're not about us you know
they're not about our daily life and and
so it's that kind of that I think this
is kind of socially yeah it's not
computer the computer but it's like how
do you connect to what society actually
needs and I think that's part of the
frustration about government not just
that it's it's not searchable but then
even if it is it doesn't really seem to
be tackling the problems around us so
I'm wondering integrating with some
other kinds of to do that absolutely
first off next time I use a better
example I was trying to get across there
is that how does it start
right no one introduces a bill for no
reason no one tries to change the law
for no reason they need something to
start it and it's something in real life
you say well why do we have a lot of
things don't kill people well people
before there were laws people know was a
bad idea kill people it seems to me and
that's true of a lot of laws that seem
to be even a lot of sort of I always
cursed me that but if the politicians
are almost the last ones to get you know
be a sea change in society and culture
and then it catches up and it's the
power to tear to your question about you
know what what are you doing to get this
to the people that need it that's about
where we spend half of our time so
getting all of the data up to a place
where you can actually do something with
it and figure out how it matters to you
how it matters to you to what you're
using it for what a business is using
for what a legislator is using it for
those are the use cases that I spelled
out there and at risk of drowning on too
long I didn't go into the ways that that
connect on the other side that's the
research we're doing now and those are
the users that were connecting to and
building around with so our our workflow
is sort of responsive so we get it up to
a level we get it out into the hands of
users it's kind of the leading Lean
Startup methodology I guess and then see
what comes back and build around that
and as I said the first users in most of
the cities that we've released this in
are the people that just need volume
they need technology to make their jobs
more efficient so that they can serve
more people or serve the same number of
clients with less time and headaches I
have no idea where that's going to go
that's the bleeding edge I mean we're
covered in blood there just because up
to today you have not been able to do
that no one was walking around with this
saying what part of this do you like
what part of this do you need now we can
do that on the internet in a way that
you can actually measure and track and
then respond and build around if we have
this conversation this time next year
that's what I want to be talking about
you
[Music]
visualization is super powerful and it's
it's something that is built-in in a
very small sense we just have sort of
word cloud type type visualizations
built in as we get more and more legal
codes up the possibilities for
visualizations and comparisons get a lot
bigger that's the use case for a
legislature on the state and municipal
level what are the guys next door doing
how did that work what are what's the
state next door doing how did that work
that's what what can be powered by this
we're not there yet and as far as the
production side so half of us I started
off saying why we were born there with
this Madison tool
Madison is going to sit on top of this
and allow you to actually draft
legislation or edit create legislation
on top of the legal code to make that
whole process more seamless so we're
cutting out a lot of the steps here just
with the state decoded to get the law
from zero to 60 or updated well then how
do you the next step is the process by
which that is made Madison 2.0 is under
development right now you can check it
out on our on our github page we're
gonna do Maryland in January the state
of Maryland and then we're doing the
federal government at the end of January
early February but we have our 1.1
versions up now if you want to check
them out it's Maryland I'd open gov
foundation.org and Madison got open got
foundation.org it's stripped down bare
bones but you'll get it sensitive
most of the law Madison or state code
broadly we define our user testing as a
group on the inside of government
mirrored by a group on the outside so in
the federal example let's say staff
assistants or legislative councils or
legislative directors people who
actually have to write the bills who
have to listen to constituent feedback
who have to listen to lobbyists who have
to listen to the news all boiling that
down into what they actually drop in a
box and vote on that's outrageously
inefficient and that was what we started
to hack with Madison but it's bringing
all of that input in to make it more
useful and satisfying to both people on
the phone line so to speak we're on the
webpage we built Madison so we could get
folks like you to share what is wrong
with SOPA in a way that we can actually
make use of so people were tweeting at
us people are sending emails people are
calling all of that is divorced from the
actual bill itself the actual work that
we're doing and the people that are
doing that work have their notice on the
bill not on the line with the
constituents so it's bringing that input
tag in on the bill that makes the whole
process far more satisfactory to those
on the outside so something I didn't
talk about yet is our user research it's
not just laptops how do you you know UI
UX research it's how do you present this
how do you introduce this to people what
do they actually want they're not
satisfied with what they get today but
what they're not satisfied is they feel
when they call that that means nothing
or that you send an email and no one
reads it
okay those are technology things we can
solve if you're a congressman and you're
reading down comments on a bill or a
staff member is and you open it you can
send that constituent an automatic read
receipt which nine times out of ten is
all that person wants just to know that
it was read by somebody those are that's
so that's where the technology problem
sort of starts to get up to the people
problem and we're never going to solve
the people problem unless the good Lord
comes down again and said booth open
everything but what can we strip away on
the technology side to make to make that
work
it's have to go so many and many times
the best accent of being paid apps it's
a very small possibility if you don't
put certain safeguards in place for
example web services that's why we so
we're saying well there may be these
opening but in many cases what ends up
happening is the best in Communication
Service right right there you can start
cutting out this class right so by
opening data you're paradoxically making
more already
that's a fantastic question
are we having that debate I would our
you know our partners in crime and sort
of our foundation I don't think we are
in that I'll pull up here our disclaimer
is we got at the bottom all content is
of course owned by its authors municipal
code charter and all rules on this
website are owned by the citizens of San
Francisco and constantly consequently
they are not governed by copyright so do
whatever you want with it the
information on this website does not
constitute legal device it's all of it
do whatever you want with it whether
that's paid or unpaid
it's a thorny question we try to go as
far as we can to ensure that this is
open and available to everybody that's
why there's an application layer on top
of that data stream that we're trying to
make more and more and more and more
useful and that's where I think we'll
Walda started this was to get at that
exact question if you've ever tried to
act when government says your city your
state your federal government hey bulk
data we've we've open data here you go
it doesn't mean anything it's useless
without an application layer and what
they give you is a government website
with all of the problems of design and
process that we've discussed how does
that get better
part of it is what we're doing part of
it is what you're doing but I think part
of it is coming from paid services you
know that's that's a big debate that's
starting to rage within the open
government community I'm sure you've
you've heard some of it it sort of feels
weird to sell some of this stuff or to
be you know in a free world and then
actually want to go make a business out
of it
that's how innovation happens in a lot
how can we benefit from that without
closing people off that's secondarily
while we're embracing open source
software so that when some good idea
comes in to us or we come up with a good
idea it's available to everybody to
build off and modify I know that might
that probably hasn't answered your
question totally but I don't think you
can ensure that there's nobody walling
off access completely at some point down
the production pipeline or the the
access pipe yeah this is a debate it is
a debate worth having and it's a debate
that's very much underway right now
[Music]
another narrative which I've seen most
which is essentially becoming as a
result of so governments I won in London
famously last year published the graphic
doom in which they essentially projected
how they were not going to be able to
provide any services other than urgent
care and child care after and as a
result having been a big and then we and
just last week but notice the slowly
haulers in the West Midlands talked
about switched into a Social Council
which again was a kind of radical
openness getting citizens involved but
again it was coming from this position
of weakness so because we have been
money and the prison is essentially in
decline that's why we should be open I
just curious as to whether you see much
evidence of that in these in the US and
whether openness coming from this
I think you are seeing that in the US
it's the world that government lives in
today and government people live into
that that's when I was talking about
sympathy for the devil
I can I can swear up and down that the
folks who are doing this wish they had a
little bit more money to do it better
they don't they're doing having to do
more with less and they don't know what
what more to be doing with that less or
that less money if that makes sense
that's where we come in frankly that's
why this exists that's why this is a
thing if our success for us is kickin
the keys over to San Francisco kickin
the keys to the federal government
kickin the keys a madison goes to the
House of Representatives that's what
they should be doing but they can't okay
there are two ways to address that right
oh let's suck it up for a little bit
longer or can we hack something
ourselves and then just put it out there
and maybe give it to government maybe
sell it to government maybe give it to
citizens or sell it to citizens I don't
think it negatively impacts the success
of those endeavors I actually think it
helps them if someone comes to you and
say I can't solve this myself it's a
very humbling experience and to have
government or elected officials actually
go to you and say I don't know a whole
lot about online piracy can you help me
write this bill I don't know a lot about
the ITC or international copyright law I
know some I know enough to get a
framework of what I want to do down and
work with those vendors to figure out
where it's addressed in the US code but
I don't know the right solution that's
why you held you know in the analog
world
hearings with witnesses to bring in all
that knowledge and that expertise to
help government do its job that's not
good enough anymore because you have
four people at a litmus table with the
internet you can extend that win this
table infinitely in both directions and
I think that more people are at the
outset willing to come and sit at that
infinite witness table
whether it's through Madison or State
decoded or any other tool if government
or their elected officials take that
humbling
and I hope not humiliating first step of
raising their hand and saying I can't do
this questions of whether the not
because what you actually want is the
people can access let's say a database
or your your application and then for
example a asking about dude I have to
leave the dog or not I would have
probably asked someone who has a dog
because I assume that he already
informed himself about what's right and
what's wrong so but that's two clicks
away from what I wanted right
and while you want to
but that would be sort of simpler you
know beyond the letter of the law the
case - what is written in the law you
can create a landscape let's say the
thousand articles that are being used
use mostly doing all-day life and then
maybe how two or three more articles are
linked to each other and then you can
see okay this is something that is
really useful for people so we have to
you have to work on that and then maybe
that's something that these are Court
decision here this is Virginia this is
Waldo's sort of the first in the the
most mature
[Music]
it does we haven't put the data in yet
but yeah that's that's next for us in
all of those instances you know where
we're facing the issue of scale with
with a hardy band of developers and as
far as getting all of the data formats
and just getting the actual data it's
sometimes a work of weeks/months all
that stuff yeah but you're right the
court decisions are applicable it's
built to hold legislation right it's
built to hold regulation all of that is
revolving around whether it's changing
or interpreting this the actual law
itself well yeah and in it the the
beauty of the framework though and the
growing feature list is if you just get
that data and get it to the right format
the first time then you unlock the
possibilities which makes it a hell of a
lot easier to get it the second time and
the third time and that's the kicking of
the keys over to government eventually
where they say wow this is ridiculously
useful and way better than what we have
we don't have to spend a million dollars
on LexisNexis over a year maybe we only
have to spend 50 and the rest of it we
can do ourselves or with civil society
health
exactly yeah well in that that was the
point I was trying to make is that the
the stuff we face is mirrored on the
inside yeah
in every case now as far as changing it
to your original question I'm sorry I
didn't get your name Felix to your
question about the the in line sort of
editability or responding to it as
you're using it that's here so to not
blow people's minds a comment on the
bottom is a lot more familiar and
comfortable to people to most of the
folks that we're dealing with on the
inside then Madison is the notion you
can edit everything comment on
everything track changes on everything
and then make it all go away because
you're not actually changing that
underlying text is very hard to get
across unless you see it so we start
with the comments and we've already got
one that's being changed and you're the
first people outside of the government
to see this and it's it's a draft piece
of legislation out of San Francisco so
somebody came on to San Francisco
website to look up San Francisco code or
just to find what the rules on bikes
were and they found something that
legislators missed it was out of date
but it was buried in the housing code if
you own an apartment around a house in
San Francisco at the parking spot you
are only allowed under current law to
park a motor vehicle there you can't
park your bike in your parking space
that it's crazy and someone said
something to that effect like this is
dumb this is stupid
can't we do something about this that's
very easy once it's identified but no
one's gone no one has the ability to
sort through all that crap you know what
one of the things I want to do with this
first lighthouse program cities is just
do a dumb walk you know and that's
something anybody can do too right we've
been on the internet all the dumb laws
in Boston many of which you know can be
apocryphal like oh you can't shoot a
whale from a driving
hard in Michigan well there are things
like that and they're not supposed to be
in there and people actually can get
ticketed or worse if you break those
Long's and oftentimes the first time you
find out about it is when you got the
cops or the ticket okay when you're
looking that stuff up it's a very very
small step and a familiar one to say
what the heck can we do something about
this and what we're finding is that when
you just do that flag it flag of it
people won't do something about it it's
very that's a very exactly that's the
fun so that was in that was you've
struck upon the way you know the
technology part actually here is not
that hard it's the the process part
which is really really really hard and
sticky
okay
[Music]
now once
[Music]
[Music]
well there there's a lot of sticky
wickets there to put it lightly
throughout what you just described
though there are a number of things that
are technology and process that can be
made more efficient more discoverable
more useful the advocacy part whether
it's right or wrong to send an ethanol
train that's here or whether it's right
or wrong for the governor to be able to
do whatever he wants and all that jazz
that's the people side of it but how can
we arm those people whether its citizens
environmental activists the governor the
state legislators everybody reporters
like you how can we arm them to be
talking about that the environmental
regulation whether or not it fits
Massachusetts and it's and the states
needs today instead of arguing about how
stupid it is that the governor can find
something in a bill that I can't as a
reporter or the army of lawyers is on
one side and I don't have one that's
really what I think we can achieve is
leveling that playing field so Waldo has
a great term where he talks about the
State decoded it's got all the niceties
of modern website design and the
expensive tools that lawyers use that's
really what this is it's giving you the
same ability to search discover and
actually find out what the hell the
problem is that the governor does or
that LexisNexis does or that those
environmental activists who spend all
day on a little section how the Madison
side of it and the annotation side of it
is gathering all of that feedback in a
useful format so an environmental group
is saying call your Congressman and tell
him vote no on the train the ethanol
train through my neighborhood act that's
made ridiculously useful if they can
just go on to the bill itself and say I
like this or I don't or fix this you
know or that this is good what you're
describing they're like Obamacare is
like the thing I always use in my
I would have given a kidney to have
tools like this on that bill because the
not the dirty secret is that both
parties agreed on the vast majority of
the bill you know I use seventy percent
there abouts that's what congressman I
so would always reference about seventy
percent of it you could agree on
but you couldn't figure out what the
hell that seventy percent was and break
that out and like pass bipartisan health
care reform that would be amazing
there's no way to do it maybe that
that's that's in one of the regulations
that's coming in later
oh one more question could you two too
much
it's all all over the place there's a
lot of opposition as you can imagine and
it's not there's a little bit of the
lack of utility you know I don't
understand what the heck this does
almost everybody that we encounter you
just show them a web page and type in
dog laws on San Francisco Code org get
thousands of references or all of the
references to those terms versus the
LexisNexis where you get you know a
tenth of that versus the city websites
PDFs where you get maybe a hundredth of
that they're like oh god this is better
let's do it
there are entrenched people as as we all
know too well who are against this just
in principle they don't want to make it
easy for you to discover law they make a
lot of money out of you not discovering
the law we assume the best in all people
and all institutions at least at the
outset until we were proven again and
again otherwise but there is a lot of
that and so that hasn't stopping a stuff
you know that I would say we do get
feedback positive and negative all the
time we do get opposition all the time
but so what we're doing it anyway
I could see how
it's been a lot of time parsing water
why
absolutely
you're right XML is not the answer that
is very much a middle step or a Waypoint
it was the data format when wall was
started that was easiest just to get
open it's not perfect
there's XML there's JSON going on a
little bit here which is it's an
improvement
there's got to be a better way no one
has actually done this before though no
one has sat down and said gee we
actually have the ability today to have
all of the laws in the same data format
all in the same database what is the
ideal way to do that we would love help
from Google we would love help from
Wolfram Alpha and I don't just mean us I
mean the whole community that's what
they do they don't do the people sign
they don't do the PDF to whatever
they've actually told us if you find
that answer
tell us we'd love to know they have
their bet you know in a lot of ways
their best minds are working on rocket
ships and Google glasses and like you
know talking computers like I don't know
what it is they're not working on this
we would love to get everything to that
level if it's ad XML maybe we can make
it attractive and say gee we've got I
would say the most valuable data set in
in the United States here can we do
something with it can we make it better
something to watch over the next year to
this point is waldo Jaquith again
they're setting it he's stepping away
from the state to code it it is we're
starting to scale it and grow it he's
setting up an open data Institute in the
US this is one of those exact things
questions that hasn't been possible to
ask yet but it is it's starting emerge
and I don't know what the answer is
though I would connect with him and stay
in touch like I said we got seven we're
gonna have another ten or so by you know
over the next month that's a lot that's
a big corpus of data on the same format
that hasn't been there before what do
you do with it
I don't know
how do we get a new city in Wow we
sometimes just do it and go to them and
say hey look what we did sometimes we
have like a city of San Francisco who
looked at Baltimore so we were Baltimore
was the first city to do to get this
done and we did it in collaboration we
pitched San Francisco months and months
and months ago they were very busy so
Baltimore was first and then San
Francisco called Baltimore and said
that's awesome how do we do it and
that's another way in Chicago we just
did it and put it up there and hope to
no one yelled at us actually they
embraced us that's not systematic and
that's not scalable that's what we want
to get all 15,000 acquire them I'll
leave it at that
and just do it all in one big you know
pushed or trance or whatever you want to
call it so that we can build that full
library doing it one by one is for us
not scalable but for you guys it is so
Boston isn't done
Massachusetts isn't done we can help
somebody here do that
Cambridge isn't done oh yeah we can't do
it all ourselves what does she think
anybody have a billion dollars they want
to get well thank you Laurie thank you
for all your questions discussing this
is a challenge as you can see because
there are so many moving pieces and I
appreciate you bearing with me and
asking good questions to help us get
this this story better if there's an
email list if you want to get in touch
with me or with our developers come up
grab me we're at found open gob on
Twitter and have a great rest of the day
thank you
[Applause]